Well, thank you, Susie, for taking the time to meet with me today.
It really means a lot to me to be open and honest with you.
Our work relationship is important to me,...
...so I appreciate you taking the time to meet with me.
I had something I wanted to talk to you about.
Lately, I've been feeling like you haven't really been fully listening to me...
...or really valuing or respecting any of my ideas or input.
For example, the other day in our meeting,...
...when I was right in the middle of giving an opinion on something,...
...I felt like you interrupted me mid-sentence and you never really came back to me.
It made me feel like my feedback or my input was not valued.
It also made me feel embarrassed in front of the other people in the meeting.
So, I just wanted to make you aware that that's how I felt.
That's hard to hear, but I appreciate you letting me know.
I'm hearing that you're feeling embarrassed...
...and not valued because I've interrupted you or cut you off in meetings.
I did feel a little embarrassed the other day.
It didn't feel good.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I have to admit this is something that I've received feedback on in the past...
...and so it's something that I really know I need to work on.
I really am committed to working on this...
...and I'm gonna really make an effort to be more self-aware.
And it would be helpful to me too if you give me some follow-up feedback...
...or I can check in with you later to make sure that I am giving you what you need.